un livre un jeu une chouette en or
massif
une valeur d'un million de francs c'est
la chasse au trésor lancé en 1993 par
deux associés la chouette n'a toujours
pas été découvertes à ce jour mais son
histoire in digne d'un film hollywoodien
nous avons retracé son histoire et même
pu interviewer l'un des deux associés
qui il ya 27 ans maintenant a lancé un
jeu devenu presque mythique
tiens c'est marrant parce que mythique
ça rime avec loïc génériques
salut aujourd'hui je vous fais cette
vidéo qui est directement en lien avec
le prochain numéro de curieuses qui
comportera un dossier très complet sur
la chouette d'or si vous connaissez par
coeur nous il s'agit de mon magazine
dont je vous reparlerai à la fin de la
vidéo
max valentin et michel becker sont les
deux créateurs de cette chasse aux
trésors d'une longueur incroyable 27 ans
je vous le disais tout à l'heure
à titre de comparaison l'une des plus
longues c'est la quest anglaise qui a
duré moins de 14 ans et pour le clin
d'oeil la mienne je peux fait une chasse
à la durée moins de 11 mois avec 10
véritable diamant pour dix gagnants
différents
il y avait un gagnant par énigmes et
c'était pas une chasse linéaire quoi si
c'est michel becker qui réalise la
chouette d'or et le livre tout ça petite
précision quand même avec sa thune
personnel de même la création de la
chouette en or et argent massif s'est
par contre max valentin qui rédige
l'énigme et les indices et qui aussi
détermine ou est-ce que la chouette va
être enterrée après il part donc
ensevelir le diabolique volatiles
quelque part en france qui devra
patienter qu'un chercheur la des terres
pour ensuite réclamer son dû parce que
ce qui intéresse est pas vraiment la
chouette finale mais c'est une
contremarque qui fait la même taille
mais qui en bronze et qui servira de
sésame auprès de l'éditeur qui remettra
la véritable chouette car contrairement
à tout ce qui a été dit c'était pas un
huissier ou un notaire qui avait la
chouette c'était juste à l'éditeur le
propriétaire quelques semaines après que
max valentin il caché la chouette le
livre énigmes sort dans toutes les
librairies
la chasse est lancée mais il faut noter
quelque chose à part max valentin
personne au monde ne sait où est
enterrée la chouette et personne ne
connaît la solution de cette quête qui
semble être éternel oui samuel humez
repos il a bien ça rime avec loïc et
c'est pas tellement un détail parce que
ça ça va déclencher une tempête
incroyable et ça on le verra tout à
l'heure alors à les enterrer ou alors on
n'a que quelques infos au final on est
sûr qu'elle est en france métropolitaine
sur le continent allait pas sur une île
à l'est par enterrer à moins de 100
mètres d'une côte maritime n est pas en
région parisienne avait pas à versailles
max 90 a été obligé de préciser parce
qu'ils voulaient creuser sous le sacré
coeur évidemment elle est pas non plus
sur un terrain privé
mine de rien ça réduit quand même
significativement le champ des
recherches et dans le prochain numéro de
curieuses vous pourrez même voir la
carte de france avec toutes les zones
impossible comme ça il reste que les
zones possibles on peut creuser on sait
aussi qu'elle a été enterré à 80
centimètres sous la terre le 23 avril
1993 précisément parce que max valentin
ne voulait pas prendre le risque d'être
repéré par la lune
donc c'était une licence max valentin
d'ailleurs c'est qui c'est quoi et b son
vrai nom c'est régis hauser et il avait
rencontré michel becker pour une opé
commercial où il devrait ainsi réaliser
réalisé ressemble une chasse au trésor
le projet il n'a pas abouti mais ça leur
a donné l'idée de cette chasse à la
recherche de la chouette d'or un truc
est sûr c'est qu'ils étaient ultra
visionnaire parce que tous les médias se
sont emparés de cette nouveauté c'était
complètement inédit un truc à ce point
et par la même occasion tous les médias
ont commencé à raconter un peu tout et
n'importe quoi concernant la chouette
d'or et comme max valentin voulait
rester un peu dans l'ombre de tout ça
c'est michel becker qui a assuré la
promo sur le plateau de télé radio et
même lui il sait lui a acquiescé des
trucs complètement faux des inepties
genre dans l'émission de christophe
dechavanne
il ne dément pas que la vraie chouette
d'or et ensevelis et qui connaît
l'emplacement précis alors que c'est
faux puisque c'est une contremarque et
ensevelis et lui ne connaît pas
l'emplacement au contraire c'est même
lui qui avait rien voulu savoir pourquoi
parce que comme il savait qu'il allait
représenter la chasse devant les médias
il voulait être certain de ne pas donner
d'indicé malgré lui de ne pas devoir
réfléchir durant des heures avant de
répondre à une question le poussin place
était de ne rien savoir
le livre est un succès de fous des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
qu'on appelait d'ailleurs plus tard des
chouettes heures les shooteuses se met
en chasse mais si le vrai trésor était
ailleurs on peut se demander vu ce que
va faire alors que max valentin
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
livre comporte onze énigmes illustré par
michel becker c'est très interprétatif
si on les résoudre correctement alors on
aboutit à une douzième énigmes qui donne
l'emplacement précis où est enterrée la
version de la chouette ambiance
après plus de 75000 ventes énormes max
valentin ouvre un serveur minitel l'ars
être d'internet et tu as connu les
minitels loïc oui ça l'est sur quel site
c'est vrai ben oui il a ouvert le 36 15
magna qui deviendra après par la suite
36,15 max val et ce serveur permet de
poser des questions aux créateurs secret
des énigmes personne ne sait rien de lui
à ce moment là il ya une espèce d'aura
mystérieuse qui commence à les entourer
via un peu mystique d'ailleurs y'a pas
que le mystère qui l'entourent y aussi
un petit paquet de pognon parce que
contrairement à internet
aujourd'hui le minitel c'est payant
quand on se connecte sur un site c'est
payant et après c'est reversées en
partie et en huit ans max valentin a
reçu plus de cent mille messages sans
compter les connexions à ce qui était
dit relance être un peu d'un forum et
c'est à ce moment là que les ennuis
commencent pour les deux créateurs de la
chouette max valentin commence à être
pris un peu pour le gourou de cette
chasse il ya presque un côté secte les
chouettes heures sur moins nombreux au
fil du temps mais ce qui reste ce au
taquet c'est vraiment un des fans
hardcore et même il se demande parfois
si leur gourou ne les ennuie pas en
erreur par plaisir ou pour faire durer
un petit peu la chasse ne faut pas
oublier que la confiance elle se perd
beaucoup plus vite qu'elle ne
s'acquièrent mauvais coup du sort par la
suite la maison d'édition michel lafon
tondent en liquidation judiciaire en
2006 et légalement la chouette d'or leur
appartient et dont va être saisie max et
michel réagissent ils intentent une
action judiciaire mais il omet de
prévenir les chouettes heures qui
lorsqu'ils vont apprendre ça pète
littéralement un cadre clairement les
joueurs attendent aussi une action
judiciaire
ils montrent une association pour ça et
trois ans plus tard michel becquart
devient le propriétaire légal de la
chouette bonne solution me diriez vous
et bien non les shooteurs sont pas
contents ils auraient préféré la voir
chez un huissier en tout cas sous
séquestre mais le pire est pas encore
arrivé en 2009 max valentin
victime d'une crise cardiaque qui va lui
être fatal meisel entammer donc en
emportant avec lui le secret des énigmes
l'emplacement du trésor
max valentin aurait soi-disant transmis
le secret quand même à son gendre mais
il a toujours été floues à ce sujet il a
jamais répondu aux sollicitations michel
becker ou deux personnes donc en gros il
a toujours dit je sais mais je dis pas
parce que sinon c'est trop facile en
l'artiste co créateur du jeu décide de
mettre fin à la chasse et de vendre la
chouette aux enchères dit stop c'est
terminé il a le droit légalement une
association de chouettes heures monte au
créneau et vous trouverez toute cette
partie détaille également dans le
dossier de curieuses c'est épique si ça
vous intéresse il ya plein de
rebondissements mais qu'en est il
aujourd'hui
et bien à ce jour michel becker est
toujours le propriétaire de la chouette
d'or et a priori la version en bronze
est toujours enterré après plus de dix
mille jours et diminuer et nous on a pu
avoir une interview de michel becker qui
nous confirme avoir tout financé et que
c'est lui qui ne voulait pas connaître
les solutions mais le plus passionnant
c'est qu'ils nous livrent comment il a
créé les onze illustration selon les
indications de max valentin
je vais vous donner un exemple comme
vous le savez il m'avait donné des
instructions pour que j'intègre des
indices dans chacune des toiles qui
devait illustrer chaque énigme sur une
des toiles la seule indication qu'il
m'avait donné était de faire apparaître
un arc en ciel qui finit par devenir
blanc pour tout le reste
cette toile est le fruit de ma pure
imagination j'ai donc créé une toile
avec une silhouette une sorte de statut
sur laquelle se reflète la lumière
blanche au bout de l'arc en ciel
interrogé par des chouettes heures à
propos des multiples détails de la toile
et notamment de cette silhouette de
statut valentin a répondu dans le vague
tout d'abord et devant d'autres
questions plus pressantes il a fini par
répondre tout ce que je puis vous dire
d'important à propos de cette silhouette
c'est qu'il s'agit d'un personnage
masculin
c'était n'importe quoi il n'en savait
rien et ça n'avait aucun rapport avec
l'énigme et l' indice unique il m'avait
demandé de placer sur la toile alors
vous riez mais c'est grave en fait vous
vous riez de sa fille le tri il s'est
foutu de la gueule des chercheurs il les
a baladés pendant des années pour faire
du cash avec son minitel tout en se
donnant le beau rôle et en dispensant sa
bonne parole comme vous êtes un peu
mentalist vous avez aussi pressenti que
le co créateur en vue un petit peu à mal
soit longtemps
voici donc l'histoire de la chouette
d'or qui aura fait courir quelques
personne c'est hallucinant comme je vous
le disais le dossier détaillé la carte
les trois pages d'interview de michel
becker etc seront dans mon prochain
curieusement magazine mensuel de plus de
50 tâche parce que oui la grossier un
petit peu dernièrement et j'ai deux
grosses surprises pour vous dans la
possibilité de gagner les cinq premiers
numéros qui sont déjà sorties qui sont
maintenant collector en gros qui hors ue
c'est un magazine pour les personnes
curieuses qui s'intéresse à tout ce qui
peut stimuler leur cerveau c'est tous
les mois dans votre boîte aux lettres un
peu importe où est-ce que vous habitez
dans le monde les frais de port sont
inclus c'est dix fois par an parce qu'en
juillet août et décembre janvier il ya
qu un seul numéro et c'est sur
abonnement uniquement pour un an
si vous vous abonnez aujourd'hui vous
recevrez donc curieuse à partir du
numéro suivant celui de septembre où il
ya la chouette d'or et vous le recevrez
jusqu'en septembre 2021 l'abonnement de
la version papier c'est 29,90 frais de
port inclus soit moins de 2 euros 50 par
mois soit au moins de neuf centimes par
jour surprise numéro une
vous avez été très nombreux à demander
une version numérique et moi j'étais pas
pour j'étais même très complètement
compte comme vous savez mais je
comprends aussi vos arguments et donc à
partir de fin août il y aura
l'abonnement la version numérique qui
existera pour 19 euros 90 pour un an
soit 1 euros 65 par mois et il ya
toujours la version papier même la
possibilité de s'abonner à la version
papier plus numérique mieux que ça on
vous permet si vous voulez de changer la
personne de votre abonnement en cours
d'année parce que je ne voulais pas que
les premiers abonnés soit lésé donc si
vous êtes sur la version papier que vous
voulez absolument passer à la version
que numérique c'est possible et on vous
remboursera le prorata des magazines qui
vous restait à recevoir
vous avez tout ça dans votre espace
privé sur le site furieuse point fr mais
pour toutes vos questions détail
abonnement même lire un extrait je vous
donne rendez-vous directement sur le
site correspond fr vous allez lire dans
la description
deuxième surprise pour les numéros déjà
parus puisque c'est sur abonnement on a
pas de stock en plus de côté disons
qu'on a là un tout petit peu alors c'est
ultra collector du coup je vous fait
gagner cinq paquets avec les cinq
premiers numéros sûrement instagram
aujourd'hui juste aller dessus à
participer merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo dites moi dans les commentaires si
vous voulez qu'on aille directement sur
les traces de la chouette d'or j'en ai
parlé à loïc on est un peu chaud pour
faire ça allait voir des vrais chouette
heures faire des interviews peut-être
rencontrer les créateurs etc pour être
très poule abonnez vous enfin l'un des
deux
entre abonnés vous avec cette chaîne
youtube c'est gratuit activer la cloche
pour ne pas rater les prochaines vidéos
ici je vous mets une histoire sur des
diamants qui ont disparu et si une vidéo
sur mon ancienne chasse à très bientôt
ciao